Joe Biden's Energy Secretary doubling
down on efforts to Electrify the entire
military Fleet of vehicles by 2030. so
we can kill people while keeping the
climate safe yep the battlefield of the
future will have EV tanks I just hope
there's a place to plug them in
do you support the military adopting
that Eevee Fleet by 2030. I do and I
think we can get there as well and I do
think that reducing our Reliance on the
volatility of globally traded fossil
fuels where we know that Global events
such as the war in Ukraine can jack up
prices for people back home
it does not contribute to energy
security so Joey this is an amazing an
amazing thing yeah they bring up the
warned Ukraine hundreds of thousands of
people have died the solution isn't to
somehow mediate a solution but to talk
about switching to EV tanks that's their
solution as people are killing each
other as we're sponsoring a war right
yeah that's what people like that lady
right there get a lot of innocent people
killed yeah that's what happens the real
true irony or even tragedy in this is
the Army comes out with its uh climate
strategy before it came out with a
Russell UK Ukraine strategy before it
came out with the China top one strategy
before the National Guard had a southern
border strategy so this is
Administration that literally cannot
protect us on our own Southern border
but my God we're going to have electric
tanks and and you can only you can only
be serious about this if you believe
there's a future where we're one solid
Collective and there are no Wars so
maybe it's just this idea of forfeiture
of sovereignty I don't know but you
cannot live in a world where we are at
War all the time brother we want to be
or not and we will always be at War we
always are at where we always have been
at some sort of war and in every one of
those Wars technology advanced not out
of some righteous cause but out of some
uh Edge that you could get on someone
some way to have a a leg up on your
enemy and this is not that leg as a guy
with electronic legs this is not that
long you know Jessica I love having you
here on the table though I wish Geraldo
was here so we could talk about the
benefits of an EV Bentley in times of
War
um not to wish any ill will on Geraldo
hi sir I'm
I'm
love you hope you're watching um
this is what is the topic again
everybody does a great job sitting in
the seat I I wouldn't go that far stop
you would do go that far okay so
um the things that I was interested in
about this are the money how it gets
paid for and then also the safety
concerns because I saw we have a
software I don't know if you're going to
call for it but I'm presumping that and
I'm just going to say that would you
like me to call for something the
firefighter who says these tires are bad
let's call for that because Jessica
would like that
it's a totally different pathway than
what most uh firefighters have to deal
with
um
it's a totally different mindset
um basically it's a chemical reaction
it's not a normal fire where
um fire makes needs oxygen to burn this
is a chemical reaction that makes its
own oxygen Jessica that's the last time
I listened to you why I don't know I
don't I didn't find that clip incredibly
uh no but I think that it's important
with people who put out fires whether
it's a volunteer or not are saying that
these kinds of fires are not as easy as
to as extinguish as a fossil fuel fire
and I believe on the battlefield though
I'm only sitting next to someone who's
been there that fires do happen and we
need to make sure that we can extinguish
them it was a good subject I've been on
more battlefields than in electric cars
that is true
don't judge when you talk about it Joey
brought this up it's like when you're
talking about war Al technology is about
is killing as many people as possible to
get the war over as quickly as possible
not to worry about you know Carbon you
know the carbon whatever and what you're
doing to whatever the stuff you're
trying to say there shouldn't be an
intersection between military gaps and
green energy I absolutely agree with you
and by the way most people in the
military would agree that uh Elizabeth
Brown home doesn't have the chops or the
experience to talk about whether or not
we need an EV military tank but having
said that I want to I want to make the
point that this Administration is
determined and on track to eliminate
American Energy Independence under the
guise of clean energy and as they're
doing so they're creating a national
security risk okay the idea that we are
buying lithium uh from China and which
is where this thing started and we were
on track to give 200 million dollars to
a company that is run by the Chinese
Communist Chinese party and and you know
Energy Secretary is like no but we even
though we gave them the contract we
haven't given them the money yet that's
a bunch of hogwash okay what we've got
is we are eliminating our independence
relying on our enemies and more than
that giving our enemies the money so
that they can jack up their coal plants
to give us the lithium batteries and
then we end up inhaling the air that is
being infiltrated by your by these coal
plants and in the end China is the only
place we can go for the critical raw
material that we need for the electric
batteries this is a destruction of
America this is a crime against America
you know uh Katie I had this great idea
because you know that I'm very
pro-environment the idea of a green
nuclear weapon so it kills everybody but
all the trees are saved what do you make
of that I mean I think the climate
people would like that idea they would
uh it's easy to laugh at something like
this because it is so idiotic and
moronic but it's very very dangerous the
Energy Secretary should be working to
get the Pentagon more energy that they
need to keep us safe around the world
this is a suicide mission and it shows
that people in Washington DC who are all
concerned about academic Theory are
focused on all of the wrong things tell
me where you're going to plug a Humvee
in or a tank in Syria when you're
fighting against Isis or in Iraq or
Afghanistan let's compare this to China
who's building nuclear silos who's going
to have a lot more of those by the year
2025. they're building a new Navy and we
have the energy secretary concerned
about going green and then changing
everything to electric vehicles and the
bottom line is this this makes the
military's job harder it makes it more
difficult for the men and women who put
on the uniform and go to very dangerous
places so that those people don't come
here to attack Americans it makes their
job more difficult so instead of making
that harder for them and putting them in
even more danger by saying hey Isis or
whoever the enemy may be can you just
wait for an hour while I try and
recharge this I'm sure the enemy will
just hold off while they're recharging
their battery they should be making it
easier for war fighters to get the job
done not harder yeah and Patty will get
killed as a result and how do you think
the grid is doing over there I mean we
should be there is no grid there's
literally no grid
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else